well hi there welcome to this edition of
just getting started thrilled thrilled
to bring you
a man that i think is so intriguing his
name is nick mohammed he plays nate the
great shelly on ted lasso i don't know
about you
but i needed ted lasso to get through
covet i needed something hopeful and
inspirational just like this podcast
just getting started so let's go talk to
nick and find out how he just got
started
[Applause]
so as promised here i'm just getting
started nick mohammed joins me and i am
so happy to have you for myriad reasons
first of all
i feel like ted lasso came along
in a very dark time in the world
and we needed a reason to smile
and i feel like nick you gave us that
with your character nate the great
shelly and
i would love to know what you were
thinking first of all before we go back
in time and talk about your previous
life as a seismologist a seismologist a
mathematician a magician everything you
can think of
i'd love to hear
your thoughts when you first saw this
character on the pages
did it jump out at you
did you have any idea how transcending
nate could possibly be
oh goodness um i guess
i guess the answer is no really i mean
you
i was drawn to the
the part and the script because you
could immediately tell that it was
quality writing there was an amazing
creative team behind it and um
but you know at that point to be fair
you know i
certainly when i went in to audition for
it i you know i didn't know exactly
where the character was gonna go and it
was only
sort of later on and part of the reason
why i i then decided to do it was
because they said oh just so you know
this is our kind of trajectory for this
character
and then
once we started filming season one
jason was very open about where it was
going to go in terms of
you know the heel turn in season two and
him kind of going to the dark side as it
were so i i was
you know i could immediately tell that
this was going to be a really fun show
and i loved that thematically it was
optimistic and you know it felt really
refreshing in that respect and you know
that was before we knew that there was
going to be a pandemic when it was going
to go out of course but um it felt it
felt like it was slightly bucking the
trend of those more sort of cynical
snarky comedies
i felt that the
kind of comedy was a little bit
saturated with those
at the time and so yeah this this felt
great but no i don't think anyone could
have anticipated how much it would
connect to an audience and obviously
we're
beyond thrilled that it has and i think
you know it's just testament to the
writers really they're just so great and
they they managed to
write such
kind of deep cat you know often you know
when you're playing a part of an
ensemble you don't get the opportunity
to to you know for the character to go
on a journey and um for it to have kind
of layers of depth and stuff but they
you know they've managed that with i
think every single character in the show
you know not just nate and so yeah it's
a true you know a real privilege to get
to play that part
i think the reason why americans
resonate so much with this as well
is it's that typical american out of
place right
and there's that feeling and let's face
it because
um
americans love an english accent they
are just riveted and i'm not just saying
just me
i i think that what's so fun for it as
well is that it's not your typical
london
show it's not taking place in london it
doesn't feel repetitive it feels like a
typical american out of water and
because to us football is such a huge
deal and by that i mean the nfl
to see a character like jason vegas like
ted lasso going and taking that real
americana personality becoming the fish
out of water
i think it's just something that
it felt warm and fuzzy and a little bit
different and strange at the same time
so
what was it like for you
getting to get to know this american
crew
and
obviously jason sudeikis being the star
of it as ted lasso what kind of
adjustment was that for you in terms of
growing up in the uk
watching the shows that you watch
and then getting a healthy dose of this
well
you know yeah i mean i you know i was
absolutely brought up on
watching both british and american
sitcoms to be to be fair um you know i
never thought that you know scrubs was
one of my favorite shows when i was
growing up as well uh so knowing that
this was a bill lawrence show i was like
oh man you know this is a guy who kind
of creates scrubs but
you know those
what both bill and and and jason and
that whole creative team they really
lead by example and
they're such positive people i remember
even on that very first
day when we were doing the read-through
of the pilot
and it was quite a big deal because
you know it was well apple were you know
still relatively new in terms of not as
a company obviously but in terms of
entering the kind of tv space and um
everyone was really excited about the
show but it still felt like a big deal
and i remember
you know the
the recording of the pilot uh was of the
read-through was being kind of beamed
over to la and new york and various
places and so we were all quite nervous
and bill both bill and jason just said
i'm sure that you particularly british
people will be um will have heard all
these kind of horror stories of
uh pilot read-throughs where people
literally get kind of cut
instantly or you know there is a meeting
immediately after the read crew and
suddenly they're recasting and things
like that and and they were just so nice
they said we just want to know that's
not how we operate
you guys are the people that we want to
do this and you're all here to stay so
just enjoy it and i remember from that
moment onwards we all just felt so i
just so valued and appreciated i mean
it's a very kind of ted experience and
that it was you know we experienced
something and we kind of came we came
away feeling very positive and empowered
actually as individuals as actors and so
yeah it you know
we just sort of hit the ground running
and it was just you know just a joy to
be a part of i can't really
i can't really fault it because because
there was a sense of being overwhelmed
um
but you know from from from day one we
were just all told to no no we're all
we're all on the same page here let's
just all have a good time and
you know it's just such a great a great
set there's no you know there's no
turkeys jason says that a lot but
there's no turkeys what was it about
nate that was so appealing to you i
liked i liked that he
i liked his trajectory in terms of it
it's quite and it's quite a a familiar
one you know the underdog who sort of
does good particularly in season one
i really liked that because you know i i
i quite like playing the the sort of shy
kind of um
introverted guy but i like the fact that
he had his moments to shine and uh
and i like the way that you know over
the course of season one his confidence
grew and grew and there's some just fun
scenes as part of that like the roast
scene in in season one where he kind of
roasts all the players um that was a
really fun one and just knowing that you
know by the end of it he was going to
get promoted i felt like
it was particularly when i was reading
it it felt like well this is definitely
a character that the audience are going
to kind of latch on to and really root
for because you know he kind of comes
from
obscurity and no one has ever really
given in the time of day but ted has
come over and has just embraced him like
immediately and and uh
and has you know run with it and that
that has instilled this this newfound
confidence in in in there and of course
you know spoiler alert obviously does
then turn sour in season two but that in
itself is really interesting and
and uh
certainly not what i think people are
expecting um and uh and i think possibly
because
audiences had rooted uh for nate in
season one and had really kind of felt
his journey as kind of going from an
underdog to a kind of a hero and getting
promoted by the end uh i think it meant
it made that fall from grace
an even sort of
harsher one and a steeper one when he
did sort of turn on ted by the end of
season two
yeah i don't think many people saw that
coming at all i mean if you follow at
all the james campbell the myth building
um obviously the hero is normally on
that ascent but it was a good twist
because
there was a whole lot of happy in ted
lasso and to have that twist happen
kind of came out of left field yeah i
think i think the only
not not valid criticism but but but
whenever i've heard anyone sort of be
critical of the show
it's it's it's where they've said oh
there's just not enough
conflict or not you know that it is you
know it it
it pushes that kind of
optimism and the hope
uh at the expense of conflict but i just
can you know you watch season two and
you're like well it's all conflict it's
you know there's so much conflict in
there and i think it's i also think it
made it feel a lot more realistic you
know the idea that
someone
i'm talking about nate but but who has
been at the receiving end of bullies and
has experienced that
often
not exclusively but often they do then
become a bully because you know when
they're given a bit of power and you
know
or promoted or kind of they go to the
next
sort of
level of leadership or whatever that is
because that's all that they have known
so they just project that onto them you
know the next sort of underling and and
then they kind of you know that's how
they sort of see
their sort of their place in the world
which is obviously very sad but i think
there's a truth to it
were you ever bullied as a child
no
no i don't think i was but i definitely
felt there were definitely times when i
felt like i was sort of
different and an outsider and you know i
wasn't sporty at all and you know i did
and they said in your intro but you know
i did i was quite a geeky kid you know i
loved science and i did magic as a kid a
lot and you know i did it professionally
then for a while before acting but um
you know being the kind of kid who does
magic tricks and you'll hear a lot of
magicians say that often that is
a defense mechanism for not being
bullied because it's a way to avoid the
bullies because you know you can just be
oh just pick a card pick a card just
pick a card and then you kind of that's
how you sort of get out of those
sort of playground situations and uh
but so no i wasn't bullied but i could
certainly um
uh
associate with some of the kind of
feelings that they had at the start of
his
season one journey
let's talk about how you just got
started because
i feel like your story is so fantastic
it wasn't as though you grew up wishing
that you could be on stage so many
actors
knew from jump street that they wanted
to be on stage and
you didn't you were heading to cambridge
but you chose university of durham and
first of all i want to know why because
to us it just seems so crazy to to
choose
a school over cambridge or oxford i mean
you you think of cambridge or oxford is
harvard or yale so what made you choose
there instead well i think it was just
partly because
to be frank the course that they offered
at durham was just more suited towards
what i was
interested in and i think there was an
element of
of being a little bit intimidated by the
prospects of
oxford and cambridge i did then go to
cambridge to do postgraduate studies so
i kind of i feel like ultimately i was
really lucky because i get to kind of i
got to kind of experience sort of
undergraduate life at durham which felt
less pressured but
was still kind of a good place you know
a good university and you know the
sciences department was really good and
and i really enjoyed studying there and
then and then to kind of then get to go
to kind of cambridge but with that kind
of under my belt sort of felt like i
just felt very grateful that i'd sort of
just had that slightly sort of stepping
stone to it i think i would have been a
bit uh rabbit in headlights if i'd have
gone sort of straight from high school
to
oxford or cambridge but um but i do yeah
you know i i loved both and um you know
we my wife and i we got married in
cambridge and we
we visited again like last summer we
love it i mean it's a it's a beautiful
place it's really nice
so then how does one make the jump
from doctorate degrees in seismology
oh interesting interest in magic and
interest in math
what was the first inkling that you had
that there was a love to be had there
well i think um i thought you know
because i was into magic as a kid i
definitely always enjoyed performing i
mean not that i ever thought that
i could make a career out of performing
and you know it's still very different
to
acting and writing and so on um but
actually it was it was probably once i'd
made once i'd then left durham and went
to cambridge to start doing
this phd
i i got involved with cambridge
footlights which is the like the comedy
sort of sketch group um which has sort
of produced you know i mean it's kind of
got this
kind of crazy alumni base of like
stephen fry and emma thompson and
mitchell webb and you know melon they're
just some great kind of great people
who've
sort of been through that discipline but
really all it was was an opportunity to
to write and perform comedy every couple
of weeks and you know
as part of that i got to kind of go to
the edinburgh festival and it was sort
of during there that i was like
i really love this and i think i love it
enough to
quit my phd as much as that was kind of
probably a crazy idea at the time um and
and you know there were absolutely no
guarantees and for a good while
particularly then when i moved to london
you know i couldn't afford to live as a
struggling actor or struggling comedian
i was working you know working at a bank
for a while
in the day but then doing a lot of gigs
and so on in the evening so it was quite
it was quite a long
a long process in terms of before i
could sort of fully say i'm a
professional actor and that's all i do
now for a living
i've only really been able to sort of
say that for the last sort of five to
ten years but
but but it was definitely at cambridge
when i think it kind of gave me the sort
of the taste for it and and possibly
even the ambition to think that it was
possible to to achieve it
i can't imagine what your mom and dad
would have said
you know what mom and dad i'm gonna quit
my doctorate and become an actor that's
every parent's dream i think
they were they were obviously they're
very supportive and you know i think
it's fair to say
that
my mum in particular was was quite
apprehensive at the choice but you know
she was like okay well you know give
yourself i remember they were like well
just give yourself maybe a time limit
like if it doesn't work out maybe maybe
reassess but okay if you want to kind of
go and i think that was that was quite
wise and i did
i think i can't remember if i gave
myself a time limit or not but i
remember thinking okay that that does
sound sensible whether i don't know
whether i stuck to the uh the time frame
or not i'm not sure now
so it was the first job that you had
that you thought
i could i can i can follow this
trajectory i can do this professionally
uh gosh
i mean i mean
in terms of the very first acting job
that i did i knew that i loved it and
wanted to to do it for a living and that
was a
comedy drama called
um billy go on the bbc it was part of
like a four-part where they'd adapted
these fairy tales and made them into
kind of modern
sort of stories
and uh i remember i got to go to ireland
for
three four weeks and uh and i got to
play one of the billy goats basically
even though the story was that they
weren't billy goats or like in a boy
band it was quite a strange story but it
was i just loved it and it was the first
time i'd kind of been away like from
home and acted and
it felt quite glitzy even though you
know we were just you know it's still
quite a standard job there wasn't
anything hugely glamorous about it
necessarily but um
i loved it and and i think technically
at that point i was like i'm gonna stop
working at the bank and i'm just going
to kind of go go for it um but again
there was no guarantees and
i i would say it wasn't really until
sort of intelligence and ted so in
particular that i feel like i've sort of
learned kind of a little bit more about
what acting is and
how to kind of
uh
to kind of ho you know i i still you
know obviously i still feel like i'm
learning tons and sort of honing my
craft and particularly on ted
i know i said before that you don't
always get an opportunity in in in the
uk sort of doing british sitcoms where
if you're part of an ensemble you don't
really get an opportunity for kind of
character development necessarily
because you know often a series lasts
six half hours whereas with ted you know
there's sort of 12
i mean i don't know how long episode 12
was of um
of season two i think it's like 50
minutes or something you know
suddenly now with the streaming
platforms you get a lot longer
uh a lot more air time and so
they just allow these kind of minor
characters to breathe a lot more in
within the writing and the scripts and
so on and i i feel like you know just
just that has allowed me to kind of
grow as an actor because
you're just able to sort of slightly
pace your performance and it can become
a lot more nuanced whereas often not all
the time but often
uh in in previous work you know there's
a lot more sense of okay we've got a
rush and if this isn't sort of you know
absolutely on point storytelling it
might get cut so don't slow down just
kind of keep on point and you know we're
really going to focus on the main
characters we're not necessarily going
to have time to flesh out the minor
parts and so yeah you know again i just
have a huge debt to ted lasso for that
as well why do you think nate has
resonated so much
uh i think um
well i guess like i was saying before in
the and i think everyone can associate
with an underdog story i think everyone
likes to believe that
uh the underdog can sort of see through
to to sort of
being good and and kind of getting on
the top of their game
uh and and i i think also with with nate
particularly particularly in season one
he really epitomized
the the kind of the core message within
ted which is that there's this great guy
to lasso who through his interactions
with other people makes them better
makes them better people
um makes them see the positive in
themselves
empowers them and that nate journey in
season one absolutely embodies that you
know this is a guy who's the kit man no
one else gives him the time of day ted
comes along empowers him bit by bit and
suddenly he's promoted and he's a coach
and he's suddenly commanding the respect
of the players and
the the fans you know the supporters of
afc richmond so we i think it really i
think it
kind of captured the show in a nutshell
did that story and again which is why it
hurt all the more when
does that fall from grace in season two
so let's talk about how people
interact with you now are they running
up to you calling you nate are they has
how has your life changed since you took
on this character
it has changed uh
and you know it's always a privilege
like honestly i can't
it's never a chore like we're maybe
there's a honeymoon period at the moment
i don't know but it's
it's so nice and maybe because of when
it came out with the pandemic and
everything people come up to me every
day like every day and they want to talk
about it and it is such a joy it's so
nice that it's connected with people and
of course
there's a
particularly with season two there's an
element of tongue-in-cheek and people
like me hey what are you doing i can't
believe it you i can't believe you know
you've turned on on ted and you've left
the club and uh
but that's really fun because it just me
you know because it's it's a fiction you
know the story is fiction so it's kind
of great that people are that invested
in it as if it's almost real life but
people are nothing but polite and it's
just nice that this show has
you know resonated with so many people
and
when people oh hello
and people you know getting in touch on
twitter and stuff
you know it's really made a difference i
think to some people's lives you know
that that show came
obviously it wasn't planned but came at
a time when i think people were really
responsive to such a positive message
because you know a lot of people were in
lockdown a lot of people were really
suffering as a result of the pandemic
and
you know it was just a bit of a
array of sunshine i think for a lot of
people and we're we're so grateful for
that
i think you should be grateful that
you're not in america because i think
people are so much more aggressive here
that i'm afraid they would come up to
you like what is your problem how could
you do that to ted
you know i think there's a difference
between the american personality and by
the way there's three dogs here so you
you will hear barking at some point
because i'm totally unprofessional but
i think that there's that
differentiation between an american
personality and a british person and
obviously the reserve that there is in
the uk
proper respect for people
i'm afraid that you might if you're
walking down the street of new york have
some people accost you
well i had i remember when i was in
america when
uh the season finale of season two went
out
uh and um i was in albuquerque
and uh and we went to the balloon
festival there and uh and i i was only i
i sort of just arrived so i was quite
jet-lagged and stuff and i kind of
couldn't believe that people were
at that point kind of already sort of
going oh nate oh hang on what have you
done i can't believe what you just i've
just seen you betray nate and now you're
hit like betray ted what are you doing
it like there was there was a an element
of like you know reality and the fiction
sort of blurring a little bit but i i
enjoy it
you know i never find it a chore but
yeah maybe if
i kind of kept to myself after that but
like uh maybe if i'd have been accosted
too many times i would have uh found it
a bit more difficult
we were saying this before with my
producer lou pellegrino we were saying
often times with actors people
can't divorce them from the character
that they play whereas broadcasters they
know us so because they see us all the
time we don't play anyone other than
ourselves and there's that
differentiation that sometimes people
have trouble with
and because you were so nasty in the end
of the season
i think that might be part of that
failure to disconnect
yeah
yeah i think i think you're right i
think um
you know i was
i remember just before season the finale
dropped
jason
texting me
just to check in which is so sweet and
also a very ted thing to do i think
because
the previous episode
had been when nate makes that really
deeply inappropriate move on keely
and
and you know the episode kind of goes
out i think on him spitting in the
mirror again maybe i can't remember now
um and it just left a really sour taste
and i think everyone was like ah i don't
think there's really any going back
for nate from this and you know
obviously they still had the season
finale to come and that
showdown between him and ted but um
you know i wasn't i was a little
apprehensive by that point thinking ah
what are people gonna think but you know
it's all part of the sort of the joy of
the storytelling and you know they've
done such a great job as writers to tell
these intricate layered stories and the
fact that they can make people care so
much is undoubtedly a good thing you
know they have done their job right you
know by doing that how much of jason
sudeikis is ted lasso and vice versa
100 just 100 both ways i would say
he's so great he's so nice he's so kind
he's so gracious
he's humble that kind of you know be
curious not judgmental it's just jason
all over he's you know he's just so
interested and
wants to make things better and so
passionate about it you know
the show wouldn't work if if he wasn't
really tech you know if he couldn't
embody that uh
it's like i was saying same with bill
lawrence you know they just lead by a
really good example and um that just
filters down it filters down to to
everyone there was a really nice
moment i remember at the very end of
season two
and we couldn't we couldn't really do
like a wrap part or anything because i
think it was still quite um
sort of locked out we could do like an
indoor thing so we just all met on
richmond green
and and i live in richmond
um and so
we were all kind of having drinks and my
wife wandered down and uh and at that
point my wife hadn't seen the show yet
and um
and she said a really really nice thing
which shouldn't be the case but but it's
true that
and everyone was there from you know
cast crew
supporting artists everyone writers just
anyone who can make it was sort of there
and everyone's sort of mucking in and
having a good time and my wife said it's
like the first time that she did she's
not part of the industry she's a
brilliant teacher music teacher and um
but she said i had no idea
who was like a lead actor in that show
who was
uh who had done
catering on the show and lots of
political catering but but what i mean
is there was no sort of sense of
hierarchy i think sometimes there are so
many stories where you kind of get
quite often a toxic hierarchy within
within production and jobs and you know
the people who are at the top behave
like they're at the top and and and that
has a a trickle-down effect as well and
it can't be very it's not very pleasant
whereas ted lasso i can honestly say
it's it's a job where everyone is made
to feel so valued and so
part of a pro everyone just wants to do
a really good job because they know that
the show has such a positive message and
has resonated with people it was you
know it's a joy to be a part of and um
i i think i i felt that that really sort
of spoke volumes in terms of how it is
run that show um it's you know ev every
everyone feels so
it's such an ensemble effort and um
uh which is good because you know that
the show is about you know
teamwork and
optimism and hope and working together
and producing something good as a result
of it before i ask you what your
favorite episode is i would be a
complete and total idiot if i didn't say
to you you're kidding me you live in
richmond did you live in richmond before
the show yeah we've lived here for seven
years yeah what what a fluke i mean i
can i can sometimes walk to work i mean
it's crazy absolutely ridiculous i mean
it'll never happen again so i'm enjoying
it i mean that never happened
no it never happens never ever happens
never so how how much of it
how much um
how much of what we see is actually
richmond like is that your local pub
yeah yeah we go we go there all the time
i mean we
the prince's head
which is the pub i mean the interior of
the pub is a set but um but the exterior
of the pub is is a real puppet on
richmond green and yeah i mean me and
brendan who plays coach bid so brendan
arrived about a month or so ago so we've
already had like drinks there jason is
living in richmond as well while we're
filming and
i think hannah might live here at some
point because she likes it so i mean we
suddenly there's like a real kind of
community
said lasso actors who are suddenly
living in richmond but yeah i've lived
here you know becca and i we've lived
here for seven years so we love it yeah
i would imagine that the regulars who
live there are now suddenly looking at
you like wait a minute
wait a minute what are you doing here
and what's this that has to be so
surreal
it is quite it is quite a strange one
and the the the the staff at the the pub
are so nice because because we've kind
of now gone there quite a lot so they
you know they they're kind of quite in
tune with it and um they've even put
like a little sort of shrine to ted
lasso they've got like pictures up and
things on the wall but it's genuinely
just a really nice pub i mean even prior
to ted lasso i had drinks there is it's
a great pub it's a really nice one so
yeah
genius who makes you laugh the most on
the set
well that's a good question i i i don't
have tons of interactions with her but
hannah hannah makes me laugh a lot as in
we say we set each other off laughing
quite a lot jeremy who plays higgins he
knows how to he he occasionally just
makes little noises which i always find
funny and then often particularly in
season one
being caught in the firing line between
jason and brendan because there were so
many scenes where there was coach beard
nate and ted on the sidelines so we'd
have a lot of just sort of times when
you know the camera's just facing us and
they would just improvise stuff because
they're so in tune with each other
because they've improvised together for
so long i would just get caught in the
firing line and often crack up because
they would change the ending of every
scene so yeah but everyone has their
moments um phil who plays jamie he
really makes me laugh such a great part
and he does it so well collar who plays
isaac makes me laugh that's a great
bunch such a great bunch
it's so interesting because you have so
many trained actors on the set obviously
um
in phil and hannah you've got people who
have
become huge names in theater and here
they are doing spot on comedy what have
you learned from them
gosh
well it's it's that's absolutely on
point because i
you know you you realize you know i
never went to drama school and haven't
done tons of things done bits and pieces
but mostly comedy um
and and you do realize you see
everyone's different
sort of
uh sort of processes in terms of uh
acting and i don't know just i i i
always
i i love how many questions
that we all kind of get to ask on set
that we never feel rushed on set which
is a a real luxury to be honest we're
very lucky for that um
uh
everyone's always sort of just wanting
to know motivation particularly when
we're filming out of order and if we
know that
the particular scene we might be doing
is gonna
uh be important for something that we're
gonna be filming you know in a month's
time or something we'll ask a lot of
questions and
we're allowed to input a lot as well
like we're always
uh
made to feel that you know there's a
script but the script isn't sacrosanct
you know if we have if we want to put it
in to our own voice or if we have an
idea for a
better tag to end on or we want to add
live a particular phrase you know
they'll they'll always allow for that
you know we'll always you know get
what's down on the page as well because
you know they've spent so many hours
agonizing over that but um but they're
so open for suggestions so
you know
what have i learned specifically about
acting um
to not to not be afraid to take my time
i guess you know
hannah and phil you know when they're
doing kind of proper kind of character
performances you realize that
you kind of can't rush a lot of that um
and um
and and as a cast of the crew they're
very supportive of you wanting to sort
of take your time and
not feel not feel rushed which is which
is great
what's been your favorite episode so far
oh goodness
oh there's so many i think
i really i really like episode seven of
season one which is called
make rebecca great again i think which
is
it's actually it's the one where
nate does the roast which is just a
really fun scene to do but also it's
when
hannah when rebecca does the let it go
karaoke which is obviously kind of
phenomenal but but more importantly it's
also where um
where ted has his panic attack and you
know i think it felt it felt like it was
it was one of those episodes
and again it's testament to the writers
where they're able to walk this real
fine line of
delivering on the laughs and delivering
on the emotion
of of certain you know certain scenes
and
i think often in comedy drama one can
sort of sometimes end up undermining the
other or you sort of sacrifice a bit of
the comedy so that you can be more
dramatic and you can sacrifice some of
the drama so you can be more
light-hearted with the gags and stuff
but um
that was an episode that walked this
managed to walk this tightrope i think
it's also when the first time that roy
and keely kiss as well so there's so
much going on in that
in that episode um
i loved that one i thought it was
terrific
um and in season two
i thought the funeral episode was
phenomenal um
oh gosh so many i mean i
i thought the season finale was really
great i mean like as in
it felt really dramatic and uh
yeah
i i i thought the open i loved the
christmas episode i thought that was so
fun and so nice
um
oh so many i love the episode in wembley
episode eight
oh forgive me i can't remember the name
of the brilliant actor i think he's
called kieran i can't remember his
surname who plays jamie's dad
and it's where they have that standoff
in the locker room after the the match
and
he does he punched jamie or jamie
headbutts and i can't remember which way
around it is now better and then bret
roy goes to comfort jamie and it's so
so powerful and it's all about toxic
masculinity and all so many things but
it was so
well acted and so so well
you know it was so well written as well
i remember thinking oh god that's a
great episode and just to film it
wembley as well was really fun and then
as we talk about the end because i love
how whenever people interview actors
they always think that they're going to
get some incredible scoop like
you're going to tell me what's going to
happen right for season three and you're
sitting here like no you [ __ ] i'm not
watch the show
but it leans on such a great ending
and that
we feel so invested um and also so angry
at the same time
with nate how much of that
was your input
i read in your you wrote on i believe
was your instagram
that the hair color change was
deliberate yeah yeah that was all
deliberate and that was more just sort
of through discussions with the
makeup designer nikki austin
um
that we
you know we wanted to sort of chart his
downfall physically in some way and we
found that interesting um
so i mean i mean
it's one of those things because we knew
that we had such a long season and 12
episodes worth of time to sort of track
this downfall of nate in season two it
was a kind of an ongoing conversation as
they were writing scripts about
okay you know because you know you never
want to peak too early and
it's like i was saying before we knew
that that um
that scene between in fact i think
actually i said to rich before excuse me
but that that scene between ted and nate
is the only scene between 10 and 8 in
the entire season which is sort of
incredible actually only seen between
just just those two people kidding i
didn't think about it that way yeah but
it's really important that it's the only
scene as well and i remember knowing
that from very early on because it's to
effectively show that kind of all that
kind of pent-up
aggression and tension that nate is
feeling he's not getting to have it out
with ted he feels abandoned
uh by ted and again it's it's sort of
allowing the audience to sort of almost
subconsciously to realize that he hasn't
had his ted time ted has had his own
issues and his own sort of demons to
kind of work on and
he he's sort of
he hasn't you know he sort of has to a
degree abandoned
nate and um
uh yeah it was just about sort of
charting that downfall and you know it
was just a very open conversation you
know they would as as the scripts were
coming in
they would sort of send me stuff but it
was always quite you know to the wire i
remember i only got that final
uh
when when nate lays into ted i think
that speech was only sent like a week
before and but they said that that's it
it's probably not going to change they
were kind of i think this is it so learn
this because i was really adamant that i
was like
it was going to be a really difficult
scene so i kind of wanted to have as
much time on it as possible in advance
to preparing things but um and only
because i'm just not that well trained
an actor so i knew i just i need as much
sort of time to sort of focus as
possible um but yeah that's so great and
so understanding and as i say so
generous about sort of sharing the
reasons behind why they've written
something in a certain way and
uh the logic behind
what they want mate to feel and so on
that you know they're really good with
their time at explaining it all
[Music]
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life geico can
help like with insurance for your car
your truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
[Applause]
i hope you enjoyed that conversation
with nick i know that i did i needed ted
lasso to get me through covet i needed
something hopeful and something
inspirational and that's just what that
show
did for me and talking to nick talking
to somebody who really wasn't sure he
could
crack being an actor full-time that this
is one of his biggest gigs yet here on
ted lasso i think it gives us all hope
that we can all just get started all
over again thanks for taking in this
episode coming up next stephen a smith
he'll stay with me and talk about his
illustrious career how did he get
started how did one of the most prolific
announcers in sports broadcasting get
his start you'll find out on the next
episode of just getting started talk to
you then